¿Pueden los aliados bloquear la mayor exportación
de Rusia?
¿Puede el mundo prescindir del petróleo
ruso?
Atentos.
Se habla mucho del gas natural por la altísima
dependencia que de él tiene Europa, pero
Rusia es sobre todo y ante todo un enorme
exportador de petróleo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2021, Rusia
exportó petróleo crudo y derivados del petróleo
- gasolinas, diesel, queroseno, semi refinados,
etc., etcétera - por un valor aproximado
de 180 mil millones de dólares.
Esto supone más de 3 veces sus exportaciones
de gas natural, por las que ingresó unos
55 mil millones de dólares.
(Durante el 2021, cada día del año, Rusia
exportó de media aproximadamente unos 4 millones
y medio de barriles de crudo y en torno a
3 millones de barriles de productos refinados.
Unas cantidades que la situaron como el segundo
mayor exportador del mundo de oro negro tan
sólo por detrás de Arabia SaudÍ.
El 70% de todas sus exportaciones de crudo,
por cierto, fueron a parar a Europa y a Estados
Unidos.)
Y amigos, amigas, este es el petróleo que
Estados Unidos ha puesto en su objetivo para
terminar de doblegar a la maltrecha economía
ruso.
Y destaco esto porque sobre este punto suele
haber mucha confusión.
En los medios de comunicación a veces se
dice que bloquear o embargar el petróleo
ruso implicaría encontrar una fuente alternativa
capaz de proporcionarle al mundo cerca de
11 millones de barriles diarios.
Pero eso no es cierto.
(Rusia produce en torno a los 11 millones
de barriles de petróleo cada día, pero una
buena parte del mismo lo usa para consumo
interno.
Además, para asestar un duro golpe a su economía
ni siquiera haría falta sustituir todas sus
exportaciones de petróleo, bastaría con
que una parte de ellas se quedará fuera del
mercado.
Tened en cuenta que casi el 40% de todos los
ingresos del gobierno ruso dependen directamente
de las exportaciones de petróleo y gas.)
En cualquier caso, la cuestión es que ahora
la guerra lo ha cambiado todo.
Inicialmente las sanciones excluyen al sector
energético, incluyendo la operativa bancaria
que permite llevar a cabo la compra-venta.
(Este es por ejemplo el caso de Gazprombank,
el tercer prestamista del país, que además
se encarga de gestionar las transacciones
de Gazprom, el gigante del gas ruso.
Pues bien este banco no ha sido excluido del
sistema Swift ni tampoco se le han restringido
las operaciones con dólares.)
Pero, ojo, porque pese a ello, muchos bancos,
refinerías, petroleras o armadores navieros
reaccionaron a las invasión y a las consiguientes
sanciones internacionales, rechazando llevar
a cabo cualquier operativa con entidades rusas.
Ya sea por riesgo reputacional, por el miedo
a que las sanciones les terminen salpicando,
a que las sanciones vayan más allá y no
les permitan cobrar su minuta, la invasión
de Ucrania convirtió al petróleo ruso en
algo tóxico.
Esto es, amigos, exactamente, lo que explica,
por ejemplo, noticias como esta.
N1(8 de marzo de 2022: Shell dejará de comprar
petróleo y gas ruso.
FT)
Y aún más.
Según datos de varias consultoras energéticas,
tras desatarse la tormenta militar cerca del
70% del petróleo ruso empezó a tener problemas
para encontrar comprador.
¿La consecuencia?
Las exportaciones rusas de petróleo podrían
haberse desplomado durante las primeras semanas
de marzo un 35% en el caso del crudo y cerca
de un 50% en el caso de los productos procesados.
Hablamos de aproximadamente de 1,7 y 1,3 millones
de barriles diarios menos.
Además, el rechazo al petróleo ruso ha hecho
que este tenga que venderse más barato.
Por ejemplo, se calcula que el petróleo de
los Urales se está intentando colocar en
el mercado con descuentos de más de 18 dólares
por barril.
(Y ahí no termina todo.
De continuar la guerra y el ciclo de sanciones,
el riesgo real para Rusia, según el Instituto
de Estudios Energéticos de la Universidad
de Oxford, es que sus exportaciones se reduzcan
aún más.
Según los cálculos de este Centro de Investigación
podríamos estar hablando de entre 3,2 y 4
millones de barriles/día.
Es decir, aproximadamente el 50% de las exportaciones
teniendo en cuenta tanto el petróleo crudo
como los productos procesados.
Eso supondría un golpe durísimo para la
economía rusa.
Incluso podría obligar a Rusia, ante la falta
de capacidad de almacenamiento, a tener que
reducir la producción cerrando pozos.
Lo que podría llegar a ser devastador: no
es nada facil volver a explotar un pozo cerrado.)
Claro que también puede ocurrir que ante
la falta de suministro global, Rusia finalmente
consiga colocar su petróleo, aunque sea aplicando
fuertes descuentos.
En ese caso, digamos que el golpe sería importante
pero no tanto.
Precisamente por eso, los aliados, y sobre
todo el gobierno de Estados Unidos está como
loco por buscar la forma de incrementar lo
más rápidamente posible la producción mundial
de petróleo.
Y eso es lo que, por ejemplo, explica titulares
como este:
(La Casa Blanca le dice a la industria petrolera
que "necesitamos más" a medida que los precios
del combustible se disparan.
El secretario de Energía dice que la nación
está "en pie de guerra", mientras que Colombia
advierte sobre la aproximación a Venezuela.
FT)
Queridos amigos, amigas, el gobierno de Joe
Biden está intentando por todos los medios
encontrar más petróleo.
Encontrar un nuevo suministro abundante podría
permitirles a los aliados sacar adelante la
madre de todas las sanciones: un embargo petrolero
sobre Rusia.
Un embargo, un bloqueo que aunque se limitara
al petróleo crudo y no a los productos procesados,
por ejemplo, supondría enviar a Rusia de
vuelta a la edad media.
Sería algo así como un Jaque Mate para el
régimen de Vladimir Putin.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo cree la Casa Blanca que
puede conseguir ese nuevo suministro de petróleo?
¿Es realmente algo factible?
¿Qué consecuencias tendría?
En seguida lo vamos a ver, pero antes, antes
tenemos que darle un tirón de orejas a la
política económica de Joe Biden.
Porque amigos, amigas, tras la invasión de
Ucrania el presidente de los Estados Unidos
ha tenido que dar un volantazo tan grande
que está haciendo derrapar toda su política
energética.
Atentos.
1(¿EL MAYOR ERROR ESTRATÉGICO DE BIDEN?)
Acelerar la transición energética hacia
fuentes limpias.
Esa fue la promesa electoral que llevó a
Joe Biden a colocar a la industria petrolera
en el centro de su diana.
Y no, no, penséis que esa vez las promesas
se quedaron en los mítines de campaña.
En absoluto.
Nada más llegar a la Casa Blanca Joe Biden
se puso manos a la obra y empezó a emitir
una tras otra órdenes ejecutivas contra la
industria del petróleo norteamericana para
dejar claro que un nuevo tiempo había llegado
a Washington.
Y no olvidéis que hablamos del productor
de crudo más importante del mundo.
Así que poca broma.
(El 20 de enero Joe Biden firmó un decreto
que detuvo las operaciones para explotar el
petróleo del Refugio Nacional de Vida Silvestre
del Ártico, canceló la autorización del
oleoductow para traer más petróleo y más
barato de Canadá y ordenó a las agencias
del gobierno estudiar nuevas reglas para frenar
el consumo y las emisiones de petróleo.
Un poco más tarde, el 27 de enero, otra orden
ejecutiva estableció una moratoria que prohíbe
los nuevos contratos de arrendamiento de tierras
y aguas federales para buscar y explotar petróleo.
Y ojo, porque casi el 25% de toda la producción
actual y potencial norteamerican depende de
yacimientos en tierras federales o en alta
mar.)
Y aún más.
También ordenó al secretario de interior
estudiar cómo incrementar las regalías y
los impuestos a las empresas petroleras al
tiempo que otros departamentos están intentando
reducir el capital y la financiación disponible
para llevar a cabo nuevas inversiones en combustibles
fósiles.
Y, claro, si recortas los dólares disponibles
también los encareces.
Para colmo, desde entonces también se ha
ralentizado la concesión de permisos para
llevar a cabo nuevas o construir nuevos oleoductos
o carreteras de acceso a los yacimientos.
Por ejemplo, cuándo les compete, las autoridades
federales tardan unos 140 días en aprobar
un permiso de perforación.
Las autoridades de Texas tardan sólo 2.
Amigos, amigas, todo este paquete de medidas
combinadas no solo redujo el suministro potencial
de crudo sino que sobre todo envió un mensaje
alto y claro a la industria norteamericana:
No merece la pena invertir grandes cantidades
de recursos en el sector petrolero porque
el gobierno lo va a castigar.
Y ojo, porque Estados Unidos hoy está produciendo
en torno a los 11,6 millones de barriles/día.
Esto supone aproximadamente 1,5 millones de
barriles menos que la producción pre-covid.
Es decir, que si la Administración Biden
no hubiera puesto palos en las ruedas, es
muy probable que hoy nos estuviéramos enfrentando
a precios del petróleo mucho más reducidos.
Recordad que ese millón y medio de barriles
equivale a más del 30% de todas las exportaciones
de petróleo crudo de Rusia.
Y claro, eso ha hecho que la Casa Blanca dé
todo un volantazo.
Fijaos.
N3(EE. UU. presiona a la industria del fracking
para que haga "lo que sea necesario" para
aliviar la crisis del petróleo.
FT)
Pero dicho esto, la pregunta que tenemos que
hacernos es, ¿Se puede compensar el petróleo
ruso?
¿Cómo pretende la Administración Biden
conseguirlo?
Pues bien…
Atentos.
2(¿CÓMO EXCLUIR AL PETRÓLEO RUSO?)
Esta es la pregunta del millón.
La pregunta que podría enviar de forma definitiva
al traste todos los planes de Vladimir Putin.
El golpe final.
La Casa Blanca y el resto de gobiernos aliados
quieren ahora lograr un suministro de petróleo
tan abundante que puedan poner sobre la mesa
el embargo petrolero contra Rusia.
Pero, ¿Cómo demonios lograrlo?¿Realmente
se puede hacer?
Pues bien, para intentar conseguirlo sobre
la mesa podemos encontrar una estrategia con
4 campos de actuación.
El primero de ellos tiene que ver con la industria
del fracking.
A pesar de todos los palos que la Casa Blanca
ha puesto a la industria del petróleo, lo
cierto es que la caída en la producción
se debe sobre todo a la propia industria.
Y es que veréis, la caída de los precios
entre el 2015 y el 2019, y luego encima el
coronavirus fue demoledor para las empresas
del fracking norteamericanas.
Perdieron decenas y decenas de miles de millones
y muchas de ellas quebraron.
Así que ahora la mayoría están centradas
en invertir menos y aprovechar los precios
del petróleo para hacer caja, repartir dividendos
y recomprar acciones.
Sin embargo, los altísimos precios del petróleo
que estamos viendo tras la agresión rusa
podrían resultar demasiado tentadores.
Pero, en cualquier caso, ¿qué podría hacer
el gobierno de USA?
Pues podrían empezar por cambiar su discurso,
agilizar los permisos, facilitar financiación
barata para nuevos proyectos y también derogar
la Ley Jones.
(La Ley Jones establece que sólo los barcos
con pabellón de Estados Unidos pueden mover
mercancías entre los puertos del país.
Esto hace que en muchos casos resulte más
barato importar petróleo extranjero que comprar
petróleo nacional.
Por ejemplo, según la Comisión de Energía
de California, importar petróleo desde el
golfo de México puede resultar un 67% más
caro que traerlo desde países extranjeros.)
Con todas estas medidas la producción de
petróleo norteamericana podría incrementarse
en más de 1 millón de barriles al día durante
el 2022.
Y, por supuesto, no se trata solo de Estados
Unidos.
(Boris Johnson abre la puerta al fracking
en respuesta a la guerra de Ucrania
El primer ministro analiza "todas las opciones"
mientras se prepara para elaborar una nueva
estrategia energética.
FT)
Luego en segundo lugar tenemos a los viejos
socios de siempre.
Amigos, Estados Unidos quiere largarse de
Oriente Medio pero al final siempre termina
volviendo.
Parece casi una maldición, pero aquí estamos
de nuevo.
Si hablamos de petróleo tenemos que hablar
sí o sí de Oriente Medio.
Y sobre todo de dos países: Arabia Saudí
y Emiratos Árabes.
Estos países son de los pocos productores
del mundo que invierten dinero en tener mucho
petróleo almacenado y una producción de
reserva, es decir, que son capaces de incrementar
sus exportaciones muy rápido si se produce
algún suceso inesperado.
Fijaos por ejemplo en este recuadro:
-Estos 4 países tienen la capacidad de incrementar
su producción en 4 millones de barriles cada
día, prácticamente el equivalente a todas
las exportaciones de Rusia.
Así que incluso si utilizaran el 50% de esta
capacidad las cosas se podrían poner muy
difíciles para Moscú.
(Solo La OPEP Puede Ayudar A Occidente A Reemplazar
El Petróleo Ruso)
El problema es que las relaciones actuales
entre la Casa Blanca y el gobierno de Arabia
Saudi, son más bien malas.
Pero en cualquier caso eso es en lo que ahora
están trabajando.
(10 de marzo Los Emiratos Árabes Unidos empujan
a los aliados de la OPEP para aumentar la
producción de petróleo.
FT)Y luego están, los enemigos acérrimos
con los que ahora Washington parece querer
buscar una tregua.
Estoy hablando sobre todo de Irán y Venezuela.
Washington se ha puesto manos a la obra.
Alcanzar una tregua con Irán y levantar algunas
de las sanciones que pesan sobre este país
podría inyectar un montón de oferta en el
mercado.
N7(Según el ministro de petróleo, Irán
puede alcanzar la máxima producción de petróleo
2 meses después de alcanzarse un acuerdo
nuclear.
Reuters)
Hablamos, aproximadamente, de 1,4 millones
de barriles de petróleo más por día.
(En el caso de Venezuela esto puede resultar
incluso más complicado.
La infraestructura petrolera venezolana está
tan dañada y deteriorada que difícilmente
podrían incrementar su producción en medio
millón de barriles a un año vista.
Pero entre unos y otros el cálculo de la
Casa Blanca es claro: hablamos de 1,5-2 millones
de barriles/día.)
A ver, no es algo sencillo y probablemente
termine en nada, pero seguro que ahora entendéis
el trasfondo de las noticias y el intento
de acercamiento de Washington a Teherán y
Caracas.
La invasión de Ucrania lo ha cambiado todo.
En Washington entienden ahora que Moscú supone
una amenaza mucho mayor.
Pero aún nos queda la cuarta posibilidad.
Prácticamente todos los países tienen reservas
estratégicas de petróleo para tirar de ellas
si por cualquier motivo el suministro falla
o se tensiona demasiado.
N8(Estados Unidos y sus aliados acuerdan liberar
60 millones de barriles de petróleo de sus
reservas a medida que la invasión rusa de
Ucrania provoca un aumento de los precios.
CNN)
Pues bien, las reservas estratégicas de Estados
Unidos, las más grandes del mundo, ascienden
actualmente a unos 575 millones de barriles.
De esta forma Estados Unidos y los países
aliados podrían ir mucho más allá y hacer
un uso sin precedentes de estas reservas para
colocar en el mercado 100 o 150 millones de
barriles - o incluso más - para reducir la
tensión hasta que las nuevas fuentes de suministro
que hemos visto fueran capaces de bombear
más y más petróleo.
Sería arriesgado pero además de aliviar
el suministro actual la medida podría ir
ligada al compromiso de reponer las reservas
durante los próximos años, lo que garantizaría
un plus de demanda que estimularía aún más
la inversión de la industria.
Estas son las 4 vías de actuación que los
gobiernos aliados están estudiando para sustituir
el petróleo ruso.
Y, junto a ellos hay otro factor que puede
resultar trascendental: la débil situación
de la economía china, la guerra en Ucrania,
las sanciones y sobre todo el incremento de
precio de las materias primas y la energía
pueden ralentizar la economía global.
Eso podría traducirse en que el consumo de
petróleo fuera menor del esperado y diera
cierto margen.
Pero dicho esto la última pregunta qué podemos
hacernos es:
¿Por qué bloquear el petróleo ruso?
Amigos, la economía rusa se está tambaleando
como consecuencia de las sanciones internacionales.
Imponer un embargo petrolero, incluso aunque
esté fuera parcial o no afectara a los productos
refinados podría ser todo un jaque mate.
Por eso en Washington no dudan en reconocer
que están trabajando en esta vía.
Y en el Kremlin también lo saben, y por eso
tratan de meter miedo con declaraciones como
esta:
C1("Está absolutamente claro que un rechazo
del petróleo ruso tendría consecuencias
catastróficas para el mercado global.
El aumento de los precios sería impredecible.
Serían 300 dólares por barril, si no más".
.)
Sea como sea, los números dicen que sustituir
el petróleo ruso es posible aunque hubiera
que hacerlo progresivamente.
Claro que de conseguirlo, estaríamos ante
un mercado muy pero que muy tensionado.
Lo que significa que de continuar así las
cosas tendremos la gasolina por las nubes
un buen tiempo.
Aunque seguramente no tanto como amenaza Moscú.
N9("Gran Bretaña eliminará gradualmente
las importaciones de petróleo ruso para finales
de 2022" Reuters)
Dicho, seguro que muchos estáis pensando
en China y el papel que puede jugar este país.
Pues bien próximamente publicaremos 2 vídeos
dónde os contaremos qué papel está jugando
china y qué papel puede llegar a jugar.
Así que no olvides suscribirte VisualPolitik
y darle a la campanita para estar atento a
estos nuevos vídeos.
Pero, la pregunta ahora es: ¿Lograrán los
aliados encontrar una alternativa al petróleo
ruso?
¿Veremos un embargo petrolero?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.